[Applause]
the masked singer reveals their first
eliminated masked celebrity if the mass
singers come out and they battle each
other and every night
one person one celebrity gets damask and
boom the whole audience is always
surprised the over-the-top singing
competition show features these celebs
taking the stage to perform whether
they're singers he was on set with the
panelists and hosts and Nick Cannon
ahead of the series premiere talk about
how secret the identities are right the
producers are just so I know nothing you
know nothing and even when I like they
like try to ban us from talking to each
other because they don't want us to
guess so like we're not even allowed to
talk about who we think but do you
really not know I don't know I know I'm
like I'm trying to guess just like
everyone else and like it's funny
because I'm standing next to them and
some of them alright looking at their
neck like yeah that's it that's all
that's a young neck that's yeah that
Nick can't be over 35 I know that Nick
you know I'm like trying to figure it
out but other than that they like keep
them in caves or a layer under the
studio or someone they have their agents
put on mass you sky's them on the way
here Nicholas two words you describe it
bonkers
[Applause]
[Music]